[Music]
he's a well accomplished computer
scientist entrepreneur and has held
several other academic and government
leadership positions known for his deep
engagement with students and his
dedication to improving their experience
on campus dr. johan ian has already had
an enormous impact at CMU good evening
as one of the top institutions in the
world were really hard-working place
there's no question about that but I
Carnegie Mellon when we talk about work
we mean something a little different
we're actively engaged in work that
matters we're at the forefront of
bringing people together from diverse
backgrounds in science in engineering
humanities public policy business the
arts to address the pressing issues
facing society were positioned like no
other institution to define and manage
the space where technology and human
life intersect and to train the next
generation to solve the problem of
global significance this new era will be
fuelled by ideas by breakthroughs in new
materials and digital technologies and
robotics how do we contribute to this
innovation economy
well it's through the startups have come
out of these universities it's also
creating a entrepreneurial environment
where entrepreneurs and innovators want
to come to Pittsburgh and be here he had
his hands in everything good at Carnegie
Mellon and there is no question that in
the few years that he has been a part of
the Tartan family
has made lasting impacts to this
institution I'm in awe of this community
and all that it represents the passion
the ingenuity the creativity and the
pride your passion fuels this great
University
you are Carnegie Mellon
[Applause]